Mì bài tháng tư, tổng bị thưu chủ tính nước tổ lâm và phụ nhân cũng đoán này biểu các ca Việt Nam dời thành phố Nam Linh Quang Tây.
Kết thúc tốt đẹp trên tham các nhận nước bên Trung Quốc,
bên ngà mi bồn nế bài tháng tư năm 2018, theo lời mới của tổng bị thưu chủ tích Trung Quốc tập cả bình và phụ nhân.
Chong tổng tổng tổng tổng tổng, tổng bị thưu chủ tính nước tổ lâm đã hồi đam với tổng bị thưu chủ tích Trung Quốc tập cả bình.
Chức khiến là ki một số văn kẹn hợp tác lưu biểu ra hành lất,
có kiến người viên trường của iban thường vụ nhân đại thòn Quốc trở lạc tế
chủ tịch chính giả tòn Quốc của người nình,
thù vướng Quốc vụ vụ vụ vụ vụ kẹn li cường,
tham và phát biểu chính xác tại đại học thình hoa,
tham khu mới hùng ăn tình hả bác,
tham trung tâm hợp tác bởn mới chỉ tựa nhận tạo ái Trung Quốc tà dàng,
dân dịm này, tổng bị thưu chủ tính nước tổ lâm và phụ nhân đã gặp đỡ,
nói chuyện với khán bộ, cơ quan đại dịnh và cộng đồng người Việt Nam tại Trung Quốc.
Cặp gỡ thân mặt các đình cựi trên ra,
hầu gắn Trung Quốc, đã tưởng dụng đớ Việt Nam,
dựa chứng chiến nghệ thuật tính nghị Việt Nam Trung Quốc,
tham dị tích của học xác Trung Quốc tức trường dục tài năm nay khoảng thời,
dụ lấy khởi động liên hoàn ra liều nhân dân Việt dưới về trung,
đế thuộc trên tham,
hay bên ra tuyên bố Trung Việt Nam Trung Quốc,
v tế tựa tượng làm sâu sắc quan hệ đối thác lực tác trên lực quan trẻ,
tụi đầy xây dụng cộng đồng trên xa thương lai Việt Nam Trung Quốc,
hỏi những giữa tưởng bộ khá gần trong thời tiens mới.
Chuyên tham cấp dẫn,
có tổng bị thương trình nước tồn tơ Trung Quốc đã thành công tức đẹp
Đánh hoop có tích cựg cho phát yếu nhỏ viêx dôn,
đồng trên ra like Việt Nam Trung Quốc,
hỏi những giữa bác phát triển tồn biến của khu bất và thế giới.